isn't it odd how depictions of demons
how depictions of weird ghoulish
devilish demonic figures are always
androgynous they're never super duper
hyper masculine Chads they're never
beautiful truly gorgeous women with
classical proportions and
representations of beauty they're always
androgynous they're always trans and the
reason for that is that the devil hates
human beings and sexual difference
basically at the very core of human
nature the difference between man and
woman the complementarity of man and
woman is right there at the heart of
human nature and the devil hates
humanity and so he tries to cut away at
the very core of humanity